(beat music)
- Chop down.
You chop--
- [Woman] There's not
enough booze for this.
- I've been rapping
since the day I was born.
- Perk, please.
Perk.
- [Perk] But I started rapping--
- Perk, right?
- Pretty great, huh?
I figured we'd just
throw a big sale on
all our Asian stuff
on December 7th.
- [Woman] Wow, that's racist.
- I would never
not serve an Asian.
- Please, wrap your
hands around that corner.
- What's up?
- Yeah.
(electric guitar music)
- Fuck.
(burps)
♪ I wanna know what love is ♪
(chuckles)
(loud laughter)
- [John] How was the game?
- Oh, how was it?
11 RBIs, 10 strike
outs, 13 beers.
That is a Delco Triple Bubble.
- Wait a minute,
you know that troops
thing is tonight, right?
- Yeah, oh yeah.
Here you go.
I already took care of it, pal.
So, we got nothing left to do.
- What's this?
Heroes and Hoes Party.
You've endured D-Day,
now enjoy Double D-Day?
Tell me this isn't real, right?
- Oh, it is now.
That girl I've been
seeing from anthropology,
she's bringing all of her
Coachella friends to hang out.
You know, the ones
that already have HPV,
so they're not afraid of it.
Courage.
- Courage?
- Triple hard
- How many girls have
you given courage to?
- Okay, that's fair.
Well, guess what,
when you've been setting up
your little Chuck
E. Cheese party,
I've been making
sure that this place
is gonna be filled to
the brim with hot ass.
The kind of hot ass that
is gonna get these veterans
rubbing rifles.
Not together, but separately.
They're gonna be
rubbing their rifles.
- They're not gonna
be rubbing their rif--
- I've had my rifle on
safety for 20 years.
(snorts)
- If you'll excuse me, I'm
gonna take a power nap.
I just dropped an Ativan.
And you can wake me up
when this place smells
like gun powder and pussy.
- Wait, you took an Ativan?
So your'e--
- The thing is, cucumber
and Netflix is $15.45.
- And we lost him.
(party music)
- I'm not saying getting
shot with a paintball gun
is the same thing.
But it stings.
- Hey, stud.
(girls laughing)
- Hey buddy.
- Oh, hey dude.
- How's it going?
- It worked.
- Yeah, it worked.
Look at this.
This one.
That's Stephanie.
- I don't give a shit.
- She's a hot
Pearl Harbor nurse.
- Yeah, really cool.
- And this one, you know,
is just hot.
And then--
- Hey, hot.
- This one is like hot Rambo.
- Hey, how are you?
- I think this one
forgot to dress up.
- What? No.
Real nurses can be sexy too.
(laughs and mumbles)
- We're playing
salute and shoot.
- Oh, troops.
(exciting music)
- Yes!
(slow motion laugh)
- Jesus, dude.
- What the fuck are you doing?
- I gotta watch both pant legs.
- My arm is asleep.
- Here, get it up.
Get it up.
Come here, boy.
This works.
- Dude.
It's not working, John.
It's not fucking working.
- All right, stop it.
You're gonna scare
these girls away
and I'm gonna fuck
you up for that.
- The whole point of this
party is to salute the troops.
That's the reason we're here.
- All right, all
right, all right.
All right, all right.
I'll fix it. I'll fix it.
Hold on.
Are you a real nurse?
Shut up.
- I slept on it...I can't
salute.
(smooth guitar music)
- I got an idea.
Izzy, are you thinking
what I'm thinking?
- [Race Car Announcer]
Downhill we go.
Fastest part of the racetrack.
- Yeah, definitely.
- Oh my god.
- What is your email?
This is gonna work, all right?
- Yeah, okay.
- Trust me.
- I trust you.
- All right.
- How's it look, Izz?
- Perfect.
- Fuck yeah, Johnny.
I knew it.
- Thanks all, for coming out.
I'm Russ Harvey.
You may know me
from Potter Lumber.
A family business.
- You married in!
(groans)
- It's amazing getting to honor
these fine veterans.
You chopped down the enemy
allowing us to chop
down our prices
on all lighting
fixtures and windows.
Now through Thursday.
(groans)
I, along with my employees
of Potter Lumber,
would like to thank you veterans
for your support.
- I just wanna say
that I do not support
our imperialist foreign policy.
- Here we go. Here we go.
Here we go.
(trumpet plays "Taps")
- Your arm is so heavy.
- Keep it up.
- I can't keep it up.
I can't.
(gasping)
- What're you doing?
- Hey, that guy's not saluting!
(booing)
- Salute the troops, sonny.
- I'm trying to
salute the troops.
- [Crowd Member] He's
jerking off with the flag.
(yelling)
- Salute the heroes, Tommy.
- I'm trying to.
- Salute the troops, Tom.
- John!
- Shut up, I'm trying
to fuck that nurse.
(booing)
- [Crowd Member]
Stop jerking off!
- I'm not jerking off.
I'll salute with my left.
(gasping)
- I'd rather you jerk your
dick with your right hand
than salute with your left.
(booing)
- You oughta be
ashamed of yourself.
- I'm not jerking off.
I'm not jerking off.
- I'm not jerking off!
(gasping)
- I certainly hope not.
Sweetheart, why don't you go on?
- My grandfather is the bravest,
strongest man I've ever met.
- It worked.
- What works?
(patriotic music)
Dude, sit down.
(exciting music)